and understand why roe v wade was not
the right choice
and you can also uh be pro life and
understand that certain states are going
to continue to be pro-choice and accept
that because you believe in the
constitution and you believe in
federalism we are now by this
uh by this ruling we are actually
expanding freedom we're expanding the
ability for people to make choices for
themselves uh that's exactly what's
happening here but these people don't
really like freedom well now here's joe
biden and and
what was nice about this is he almost he
almost did it he almost put together a
completely coherent sentence
almost kind of maybe a little i mean so
the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
okay he almost you sort of see what he
kind of was trying to say there but
again the decision does not say no one
can make a decision about abortion the
decision just says it goes back to the
states and the states will make the
decision about abortion and if you want
to get an abortion and you're in a state
that says you can't have an abortion or
you're past the time limit or whatever
then go to california and have your
abortion party and everything else he
just can't even say one straight up
clear honest statement but the question
really is why are they going so crazy
over this why is this the number one
issue for these people now i think it's
partly because the machine just spit
this thing out with this leak and what a
beautiful thing for these guys they
think they have something that can push
them over for the midterms right they
think they can fire up the basin enough
they think they can get all the
blue-haired crazy people and the woke
screaming lunatics to scare enough of
the good liberals to think that the
republicans and the conservatives are
coming for women and the rest of it but
of course you know this and this is the
point this is all covering up for the
absolute disastrous policies that's what
it is but but their their goal is to
make you all think that republicans hate
women and they want to control their
bodies that's what they're going for
that's what they're trying to convince
you all of